welcome back so we're talking about data
science and we've talked about how you
can ask questions and answer them with
data and that it's this this feedback
process so I really want now to talk
about the nature of data so the nature
of your data because this plays a big
role in what kinds of questions you can
ask and answer how you collect the data
how you store it analyze visualize the
types of models you can build with
machine learning so the nature of data
is very very critical and there's lots
of types of data out there there's a
huge variety big data sparse data and
everything in between and nowadays we
hear a lot about Big Data this is kind
of a big buzzword big data so everyone
is competing to see whose data is bigger
you know companies are buying new
equipment to measure things more
accurately so they can collect more and
more data oftentimes you know big data
has benefits so there's been a lot of
successes from Big Data so think of
Google Image Search or even Google
search in general huge success of big
data but there's a lot of times a lot of
occasions where you're collecting big
redundant data data that is not actually
adding value by just collecting more of
it and so I think it's not always
important to stay in the Big Data regime
but sometimes we want to be thinking
about what I'm gonna call smart data
this is a bio-inspired principle so I
think about you know animals a lot
insects when they're flying they're not
collecting huge data about their
environment they have very targeted
sensors they have strain sensitive
neurons on their wings a few of them
that are collecting just the right
information then they listen to these
strain sensors the smart data to inform
them about the the system they're
interacting with so sometimes big data
makes sense sometimes you want to go to
the smart data limit where you actually
learn to listen to a massive sub sample
of your data
instead of all of the data you listen to
some of it that's maximally informative
okay
so let's talk about the types of data
you have the nature of your data so
oftentimes your data you know it might
come in a big Excel spreadsheet that
happens all the time someone sends me an
Excel spreadsheet so it's not always in
a fancy database
you know you might email your colleague
and say hey I need this data to answer
this question and he emails you or she
emails you a big Excel spreadsheet okay
and in that spreadsheet there might be
numbers and letters and categories and
all kinds of messy stuff that's what you
normally find so there's numerical data
numerical data or things you know
numbers like zero point nine seven two
is an numerical data you might expect to
see they might be categorical so
categorical so for example if I have a
bunch of images of cats and dogs I might
have a label is it category A or
category B or is this part type A or
type B or type C so categorical data
comes in a few categories you know in
this case a B or C and then there's a
there's cases which are less less
clear-cut not just numbers or categories
but something that's somewhat in between
so these are called ordinal so let's say
you have a 5-star recommender system
like a rating system so I have one
through five stars it's discrete yeah
kind of like these categories but there
is an order to those five is bigger than
one so this is called ordinal and in the
real world what you're going to have our
mixed data types you're going to have
images which are millions of numerical
values millions of pixels each with a
numerical value and each image might
have a category or a few categories
there's a dog and the cats something
like that categories describing the
numerical data so that that's very
common another key distinction about the
nature of your data is whether or not
it's high dimensional or low dimensional
okay so a high dimensional data and this
is a very subjective
categorization high dimensional and low
dimensional so one person's low
dimensional might be someone else's high
dimensional but I'll give you some
extreme examples ok so high dimensional
data are things like images are
inherently there's many degrees of
freedom or dimensions used to describe a
megapixel image there's a million picked
pieces of pixel information that you use
to describe an image so if I have an
image here let's make it a cat then this
this image data is high dimensional by
nature of the fact that there's a
million pieces of information to
describe that lower dimensional I mean
to some extent for humans anything
higher than three dimensional is high
dimensional because we can see in three
dimensions but low dimensional is you
know smaller than that so maybe if I
have one measurement in time you know a
time series of one measurement or two
measurements I'll give you an example
low dimensional maybe I'm running an
experiment I'm trying to design a new
super alloy and it's super expensive it
cost me $50,000 to bake and test this
new super alloy and after this very
expensive procedure I get out four
numbers okay I get out these four
material properties that describe that
material that's kind of a low
dimensional output there's only a few
numbers that cost a lot to get and I
only get a few numbers out whereas you
know images are cheap and very high
dimensional okay so low dimensional high
dimensional that's a key a key
distinction another major distinction in
in data science in the nature of data is
whether or not your data comes with
labels so to some extent is it labeled
or not and this makes a huge difference
in terms of what machine learning
algorithms you can use to model your
data so if you have labels let's say in
this case it didn't just say it wasn't
just a cat but I knew that it came from
the category there was this label that
this is a cat and maybe someone else you
know I also have images of dogs and
someone labels those
dog so if I have labels I can do a lot
with my data I can build models that
will tell me what is the difference
between dog and cat and I can build an
algorithm that in the future when I take
a picture it'll tell me oh that's a dog
or that's a cat so label data versus
data that's not labeled makes a big
difference and there's a huge
distinction there's almost like two
families of algorithms whether or not
there are labels or are not so if there
are labels then this is called
supervised learning algorithms and if
there's not labels then this is called
unsupervised okay and so these are huge
categories of machine learning
algorithms based on whether it's
supervised door unsupervised okay good
another key distinction that I think
about a lot is not just how big my data
is in terms of kind of the dimension of
one example so I think of these as
example data but how many examples do I
have do I have many or few examples okay
so that's another really really
important important distinguishing
feature so for example Google presumably
has many high dimensional images in
their image library if I take a time
series measurement I have some sensor
and it's measuring one thing but I'm
measuring it at an you know every
millisecond for ten hours
I have many examples of low dimensional
data okay that's interesting and the
flip side I might have data where I have
lots of measurements but only a very few
examples so what are some examples of
this I think of the Human Genome Project
I might have one person where I've
sequenced their whole genome so I have
all of this massive high dimensional
data for one person's genome or maybe
maybe five people you know it's very
expensive to sequence a whole genome or
at least it was ten years ago and so I
might have a very few examples but a ton
of data for those few examples and so
that's often called
deep data or you have like a ton of data
but not that many examples okay and I
think that the kind of intersection of
many or few and high and low dimensional
there's some really interesting
categories of problems
so typically neural networks for example
work really really well when you have
many examples so neural networks are
great for many examples of labeled data
not so great for a few example data okay
so that's a huge huge distinction you
know what what just general type of data
is it high D or low D does it have
labels are there many or few and then
another one I think of and this is the
last one I'm going to write down and I
think of this a lot because I work with
physical systems engineering systems
systems from science where we know
Newton's laws exist and are true and I'm
dealing with systems that are evolving
in time according to physics is your
data temporal in nature is is it kind of
temporal or does it come from physics is
there some physics or dynamics that
describe your data that's also very
important so if our my many examples
correlated in time or are they kind of
discrete examples like picture of cat
picture of dog okay is it a movie or
just a sequence of random images that's
how I think of it okay and these are
just you know some of my favorite
categorizations of the nature of data
there's a lot I'm glossing over you can
have a lot of more subtlety and mixed
types you know in the Human Genome
Project presumably they collected extra
information about that person you know
what are their diet what's their blood
pressure what's their age things like
that so you have extra information and
this all goes into practical questions
about how would you store the data
how would you collect the data how would
you what computational hardware and
architectures would you use you know
what databases would use to store the
data what machine learning algorithms
would you use to process the data can I
do it on my laptop or do I need a
supercomputer those are all very
important questions and then the last
thing I want to talk about
and and this is you know if I'm gonna
build a model a machine learning model
for this data to answer questions I also
need to know which of the data I have
that I'm going to train my model on what
are the inputs and what are the outputs
and hopefully you've collected all of
this rich data so you were measuring
both the inputs and the outputs of some
process but you might want to then use
that model to predict the outputs given
new inputs so you have to decide in the
future what's going to be easy to
measure and what's going to be valuable
to predict and so that's you know a
really important kind of human step in
this process is determining from this
data what are you gonna call inputs and
outputs in this process and so of course
as with everything I'm a big fan of
feedback in general there are these kind
of inherent feedback signals throughout
this entire process so you know the type
of data you have determines often what
types of inputs and outputs and what
types of things you can model what
questions you can ask and answer again
that tells you you know should I be
collecting more data or listening to a
subset of the data and this is kind of
an interesting cycle okay so you've got
to think about what's the nature of your
data it's critical in what types of
questions you can ask an answer okay
thank you